The Predator gets a makeover — and gets outfoxed
by a dog. "Prey" is more than just "Predator 5."
Here's how the prequel kept the franchise fresh.
In "Predator 2," the Predator's ship
features artifacts and weapons spanning
many times and cultures. As a result, each
new "Predator" film can really pit the
creature against any group of humans. Enter
"Prey," which follows Comanche warrior Naru
as she battles European soldiers and
the Predator in North America in 1719.
In "Prey," our beloved Predator is
traveling light on a vacation to Earth.
While the humanoid alien is shown using its
invisibility cloak mode on multiple occasions,
the creature doesn't rely on any of its other
gadgetry as much as it has in previous films.
That isn't to say that all of the high-tech
alien weapons are absent, merely that this
era's Predator prefers to stab and impale its
prey rather than blast them to smithereens.
"It fought and killed a bear with its hands."
Since the film does take place 300 years ago, it's
possible that this version of the Predator is not
quite fully evolved in the weapons department.
While the alien hunter is certainly far more
advanced than humanity in 1719, it doesn't
appear to have all the tricks and upgrades of
"Alien vs. Predator." More importantly, this
makes it a much fairer contest between the
humans and the alien creature since it isn't
drawing upon an endless arsenal of options.
However, it would be interesting to
witness how the creature fares without
the use of its cloak technology at all, since
that still allows it to sneak up on humans.
Animals, at least, can sniff the creature
out, even if they can't see the Predator.
The success of John McTiernan's "Predator" film
can be attributed to its survival horror elements.
Dutch and his team are out in a jungle,
surrounded by trees. Constricting the space
puts them at the mercy of the alien whose use
of camouflage and the environment makes members
of the group sitting ducks. Similarly, other
"Predator" movies, especially the good ones
that try to honor the original, rely on this key
element, as the alien has a place to hide, sneak,
and strike from. To borrow a Terry Silver
quote from "The Karate Kid Part III,"
"If a man can't see, he can't fight."
"Prey" features some similar situations to
the first "Predator" where there are moments
of confinement. But it also poses a new question,
in asking how good the Predator is in open spaces.
The Great Plains boast vast amounts of
open land with only grass in the distance.
In theory, this would be the best place to lure
the alien creature to, since it removes the high
ground aspect and lets any sudden movements be
more identifiable. However, "Prey" confirms that
the creature is as lethal in this setting as in
others. One especially memorable scene finds the
beast chasing Naru and a fellow Comanche warrior
across an open field, a set piece reminiscent
of the velociraptors stalking the hunters through
the long grass in "The Lost World: Jurassic Park."
The Predators hunt other life forms for both
sport and pride, claiming ritualistic trophies
from their victories. They want to prove their
superiority, quite often in the most brutal way
imaginable, while maintaining a code of honor
for their prey. This code is questionable,
though, since it isn't ever a fair fight if the
opponent fails to have intergalactic weapons in
their possession. So it goes without saying
that their moral compass is a bit skewed.
In other "Predator" films, the audience witnesses
the alien hunter go after humans as their main
target, identifying them as worthy adversaries.
Ironically, humans aren't even considered apex
predators in our own world, since we don't
eat everything we destroy. But in "Prey,"
the Predator goes after several creatures, not
just humans. It faces off in two big contests
against a wolf and bear. The wolf shows
its nose is key in this encounter. However,
it proves to be no match for the Predator's
sharp blades. On the other hand, the bear
strikes some real blows to the creature. If the
Predator's cloaking ability had been removed,
there's a good chance it might have struggled
to deal with the bear's sheer power.
Next to its age-old nemesis the Xenomorph,
the Predator's design is one of cinema's
most distinctive and iconic creatures. From its
trademark dreadlocks to its seriously gruesome
face, the universe-traversing hunter would be
pretty easy to pick out in a lineup. However,
in "Prey," the Predator looks a little different,
showcasing a leaner gladiator aesthetic.
While it's still easily identifiable,
it did receive a makeover with a few tweaks to its
physical appearance that fans noticed immediately.
Dan Trachtenberg explained why he
felt it was necessary to change
the creature's appearance for
the film, telling Time Out,
"I wanted to make sure the head
was more proportional to the
body [...] This Predator is much slimmer
and less armored than it's ever been.
It's more 'creature.' It's
still hulking and ferocious."
At San Diego Comic-Con, Trachtenberg
also revealed that he and his team
included goop around the Predator's face
to make it more disturbing to look at.
In "Predator 2," the creature navigates
a concrete jungle with relative ease and
fluidity. Despite the unique surroundings of
Los Angeles, it understands what it needs to do
to hunt and survive in this setting. The reason
for this is likely due to the events of "Prey,"
which serve as an important lesson for all the
other Predators of what not to do when on Earth.
In "Prey," the Predator falls
into a quicksand-style mud trap,
which ultimately plays a major part in its
downfall. Like anyone else in such a pickle,
it struggles to get out of this situation,
especially as it had been injured beforehand,
which made its predicament even worse. But it does
lead one to wonder if perhaps quicksand didn't
exist on any of the other planets the Predaor
had visited before. It's also possible that
this Predator is still young and inexperienced
in its hunts. Maybe Earth is its first rite
of passage and it's trying to prove itself,
quickly and recklessly. That would also explain
why the creature fights the bear in the river,
when the water isn't conducive to its cloak mode's
effectiveness and helps to reveal its presence.
Throughout all the "Predator" films, the
alien has taken on many formidable foes
who have proven to be worthy adversaries
and even victors. From the terrifying
Xenomorph to walking muscle mountain Dutch
Schaefer, played by Arnold Schwarzenegger,
the alien hunter has faced off against the
best of the best across the planet. In "Prey,"
the Predator gets too cocky for its own good,
failing to properly determine all of its threats.
Not only does the Predator dismiss Naru's
abilities, but it also overlooks her dog.
While the Predator manages to put down a wolf, a
bear, and countless other human beings throughout
the movie, it eventually falls to the outstanding
teamwork of Naru and her dog. One could even argue
that it's the dog that makes the difference
here, as Naru is left exposed in the final
fight against on two occasions. After previously
saving the Comanche warrior from the Predator,
the four-legged mutt appears at the end
of the film with an ax when Naru needs it
most. In many ways, Naru's faithful
friend is the true hero of this story.
Remaining quiet is often the key to
successfully capturing prey while hunting,
since it helps to maintain the element of
surprise, allowing the hunter to strike hard
and fast. In the previous "Predator" movies,
silence hasn't always been possible. While
everyone tries to keep their lips sealed and their
mobile phones on silent when in danger, groups of
people tend to talk or move around, even when the
imminent threat of total annihilation looms near.
"There's something else out there!"
On the other hand, "Prey" is a quiet film. Besides
the occasional bird chirp or rustle of the leaves,
there's an intense stillness and quiet to the
Great Plains. In many ways, this setting is
ideal for the Predator, as the silence ensures the
creature is able to hear the footsteps of its prey
from a mile away. However, it's equally
effective for the intended victim, too,
since any sudden movement will alert them
of a problem on the horizon. As an example,
Naru manages to find and
attack the unaware Predator
simply because she's quieter than the alien. Talk
about using the hunter's tactics against them.
There's an argument to be made that the "Predator"
franchise falls firmly under the umbrella of
horror. After all, the whole concept of
an almighty alien hunter chasing after
humans is frightening, plus the creature's
unmasked face is pure nightmare fuel. Plus,
the franchise's previous films are jam-packed
with jump scares, with victims never knowing
what's lurking around every corner. In "Prey,"
some of those scary elements remain, but there's
something different about this version. This time,
the Predator seems far more savage than before.
This alien creature uses its raw power and
lightning speed to wicked effect. It moves with a
resolute purpose and uncanny brutality that
has been lacking in the franchise's recenting
outings. While brutality is a
key element of the slasher genre,
the Predator isn't coming at people through
their nightmares or hiding behind doors and
walls. It doesn't hide in the shadows
like a boogeyman. Instead, it charges
into battle like a warrior that isn't afraid
of anything, which is somehow more horrifying.
It's a foregone conclusion that the
better a warrior's class of weapons,
the better chance they have of success. In
the previous "Predator" films, the hunter's
shoulder cannons have made all the difference in
battle. In "Prey," the creature prefers to use
hand-to-hand combat to dispose of its opponents,
but it isn't averse to pulling out the big guns
when absolutely necessary. But that doesn't
mean their superior weapons win out in the end.
While literally stuck in sinking mud, the
Predator points its weapon at Naru and
fires. However, it fails to realize
that it isn't wearing its helmet,
which features incredibly accurate targeting
capabilities. It also doesn't notice that
Naru has carefully set up the helmet to lock
the Predator in its crosshairs. As a result,
the creature ends up on the receiving end of its
own attack. Again, it proves that technology can
be useful in a fight, but a strategist will
always trump an aggressive brute in the end.
Consistent across the "Predator" franchise
is that the extraterrestrial beings believe
in a warrior's code. They don't hunt for a
tasty snack or out of self-defense. Instead,
they take on opponents they believe will
provide a tough, daunting challenge,
or who would make excellent sparring partners,
like in the Yakuza swordfight in "Predators."
For these alien hunters, it's about testing
their superior skills and advanced smarts as
they attempt to prove they are worthy enough to
be a part of their clan. Throughout the "Predator"
films, this code seems to remain intact.
However, "Prey" explores what happens if the
alien isn't actually all that good at identifying
threats or challengers, for whatever reason.
"This is as far as you go."
Undoubtedly, the Predator sees the Comanche
warriors as worthy enough to challenge and hunt.
It stalks and battles them, coming out
on top on several occasions. However,
the creature fails to see Naru as a threat from
the get-go. She demonstrates a warrior spirit
and natural fighting ability, even if some
of her own people doubt her skills. However,
the Predator basically scoffs at the thought of
taking her on. But it's Naru's resilience and
ingenuity that bring down the alien hunter
in combat. Imagine how different "Prey"
would have been had the Predator never
underestimated Naru in the first place.